everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round 4 of
the 2015 sync Feld cup our competitors
today whites gonna be played by Wesley
snow we took a look at him in round 3
had a very good performance got a
victory there
his opponent today is Levon Aronian who
has not lost he has one win and two tie
so far coming into round number four so
he's playing extremely well not having a
lot so far is always a good thing so
we'll go ahead and get it underway so
decided to go and start with pond d4 we
seen Knight f6 upon c4 pawn to e6 and
then Knight to c3 and this was a little
surprising you don't see the
nimzo-indian defense played that often
most players is white usually try to
avoid these lines but just because it
gives blacks so much play and so instead
a lot of times we're seeing now Knight
to f3 is kind of this standard so when I
saw Knight to c3 I was kind of shocked
because I knew immediately that Levon
Aronian would go to the nimzo-indian
defense put a lot of pressure and if
you're not too familiar with this
defense locking down this Knight Black
has a few options can either a give
double pawns here potentially how you
know white wants to defend this could
play bishop here to d2 if we wanted to
but really just paying down this Knights
so that this Knight can't protect the
square here on e4 now becomes a very
important square on the board and blacks
looks to try to just dominate these
light squares eventually get his pawn
here to d5 he already has his nights
here on f6 controlling the square and so
just trying to control this and then
from there black has a lot of good
chances what we see next is pretty
surprising white typically is going to
respond here with Knight to f3 many
times pawn to e3 or if just wanted to
play the Bishop to d2 or Queen to c2 to
make sure there's not a double pawn here
on the C file those are always common
but Wesley's nut so decides to go ahead
and just bring out some creativity and
place pawn to f3 getting ready to push
forward with pawn to e4 saying that hey
even if
you're going to pin down my Knights I'm
still going to have the material to hold
down the square here on e4 black now
plays pawn to c5 just protecting a
little bit this Bishop here on b4
completely okay if Wesley so decided to
take here on a c5 can always take back
with the Bishop even if you want to kind
of an in-between move Knight to c6 start
to control the stern of the board having
your opponent give up that central pawn
is always good but white decides not to
go ahead and do that instead place pawn
here to d5 so being pretty aggressive
with his pawns early on castle on the
kingside pawn appears ephors we talked
about so very aggressive pawn chain from
Wesley so pawn here to d6 just opening
up the board for his knight to get
involved since it can't come here to c6
get his Bishop involved if he wants to
so a critical move to go ahead and move
that there now Knight to e2 because if
we look at it where is really white
going to move from here I really don't
like getting the bishop involved yes
could kind of pin down this knight right
here but then pawn takes here on d5 I
would see pawn recapture Knight over
here to d7 it's just kind of tough right
now for white I think his king is gonna
have a hard time being protected for
very long so getting that Knights
involved into the action protecting the
king a little bit makes sense to me he
still has the option to castle on the
King side it's just gonna be chaos if he
tries to castle on the Queen's head
there's just not enough material to kind
of hold down any sort of protection but
if he wants to maybe get his knight up
here to f4 could always bring it here to
g3 get his LightSquared Bishop involved
castle on the King side and then just go
straight kamikaze with some of these
pawns pushing forward has an a semi-open
file potentially or even an open file
with his rook here on the F file if he
does that kind of like a Kings gambit
where you give up this material here so
that you have an avenue for your rook to
attack we see pawn here's a6 not sure
this is aggressive as black could have
played he had a few different options to
be a little bit more aggressive could
have just taken here
with you know II takes here on d5 we
could have had the recapture here then
bring the night over here to d7 as we
talked about maybe Knight to f4 now
that's kind of the move that we kind of
discussed night here to a5 outpost move
maybe pawns to a3 Bishop back here to a5
can't really come up here pawn to b4
because there's the protection there on
c5 so I think this is maybe a little bit
more aggressive that black could have
played that but decides to go and play
pawn here to a6 looking later if he
wants to move forward with pawn here to
b5 we see kind of a stop to that with
pawn here to a for stopping any push
here on b5 a bishop coming back here to
a5 just wants to make sure this pawn
doesn't push up any further which is
completely reasonable Bishop here to d2
taking away that pin that black has and
now we do see some capturing in the turn
of the board so pawn takes pawn
recaptures med over here to h5 and then
g3 and g3 kind of signifies that white
is all in you're really not gonna be
looking to castle on the King side if
you've moved your F and your Jeep on up
so White's pretty much gonna be throwing
everything in the kitchen sink in his
opponent try to have a very aggressive
attack and maybe something good will
happen
I'm from black standpoint his King's
pretty safe he hasn't moved any of his
pawns this is pretty good he's gonna
need to take advantage of all this air
in front of the King safety for whites
and then just see if he can kind of chip
away and find a weakness in this defense
black responds with Knight here to d7
does need to get that night involved in
they can come here to c6 so Knight to d7
is kind of a only logical move and it
very nicely ties into bring it a here to
e5 nice little outpost move so not too
many options for Levon Aronian in this
spot [ __ ] bearded g2 pawn down here to
b5 trying to just open up this as we
talked about before pawn appears to g4
and then pawn down here to be 4 so
pretty interesting to go ahead and say
hey you can take my knight if you want
to I'm gonna go ahead and take your
knight over here but this would just
completely blow up the King side the
board I think it would be interesting so
we didn't see this
in the game but pawn takes here on h5
the Queen can immediately come down here
to h4 g3 is a nice little move it only
not only protects the king but it also
protects this pawn here on h5 which is
good why it's not gonna have to really
worry too much about the double pawns
here it's gonna be easy for him to
exchange that off the board at some
point now if the pawn takes the Knights
we have the pawn recapture this
interesting game for sure this didn't
happen in the game instead why decided
to go ahead and play Knight back here to
b1 somewhat of a passive move I will be
honest with this knife it really can't
move anywhere now it can't come to a3
can't come here to c3 it's blocked here
on d2 so Levon Aronian made an
interesting move basically saying I'm
gonna trap my knight which for the most
part kind of traps this rook this rook
can't come up here to a3 it doesn't do
anything here on a2 so this is kind of
stuck interesting move not one that I
would recommend but decided to go ahead
and play this in the game now Queen to
h4 this just opens up the door to attack
the King we said there's not much
defense here on the King side the Wesley
snow he's going for it and so this is
kind of what he has to worry about King
here to f1 so now we know for sure can't
castle and then Knight here to e5 the
nice little outpost move so this game in
my opinion it's kind of playing itself
for Levon Aronian he doesn't have to do
too much on board it's he's just kind of
going through the motions now the next
move I did think was pretty interesting
a White had the option to go ahead and
take pawn takes here on h5 then we see
pawn here to f5 trying to open up the
door
a bishop here to e1 interesting I think
making the Queen move here but you can
see how different it is from what
actually played in the game and Wesley
so decided to play Bishop here to e1
first and I think you kind of mixed it
up a little bit as far as how he played
it now the Queen comes back here to f6
instead of the pond coming down here to
f5 but this is a much stronger attack
now after the pawn takes here on h5
which is what we see on the board and
now Knight sand
f 3 is just it's deadly we see the pawn
hon on the F file we see the pawn on the
G file both gone so you know LaVon is
going after all the defense in front of
his opponent and this is really
difficult to deal with it's really bad
you know Bishop can't really take here
on f3 because then Queen takes here on
f3 and then what does white really do
here King can't really come here because
then Bishop here to h3 that's gonna be a
quick checkmate
if instead the bishop comes here to f2
then all of a sudden just the Queen's
gonna take care on h1 that's not gonna
be good as well so we will come back on
board and after the knight takes here on
f3 we see the bishop - f2 and so pretty
much these bishop pairs they're kind of
taking the place of what pawns usually
do and that's just stick in front of the
King and make sure that your opponent
does not destroy you not usually what
you want your bishops to be doing we now
see Bishop here - g4 I think a huge
opportunity was missed black kind of had
a huge move of just queen - 2 - b - and
yes it only does take a pawn right now
but it just is threatening to take this
rook right away there's no place that
this Knight can really go we said it
can't come to a 3 or c3 you can't really
come to d2 just because the knight could
just capture it right away the Queen's
protecting it so Queen to b2 is actually
pretty deadly I'm not sure if Levon
Aronian just didn't see it but decided
to go instead I get his light square
bishop involved into the action did miss
a huge move though I think so Bishop
here - g4 Queen over here to see one
another mistake I'm not sure that Wesley
really thought about too long he does
want to protect this pawn here on b2 I
give that but I think he could have
played Knight - D - yes the pawn could
fall but the rook would not fall the the
Knights kind of outside of the danger
zone right now so that's gonna be
completely fine I can always take just a
knight if he needs to so this is gonna
be fine but I'm bored decided to go and
play Queen over here to see one
all night here to d4 we do see capture
pawn recapture pot up here to e5 pawn
recaptures here on e5 Knight here to d2
so eventually getting this Knight back
involved into the game recover here to
c8 so activating the big boys the rooks
are now getting involved into the game
if you kind of look at the board state
we always talking about its the pieces
that you have in the game more so than
just the pieces you have on board Black
has an activated rook here on c8 a white
really can't do anything with his rooks
this rook over here on h1 is not moving
the rest of the game it just does not
it's not doing anything the rook here on
a1 it's probably not gonna move the rest
of the game it's just kind of stuck
right here it's not doing too much these
bishops can't really be aggressive there
this one definitely can't move it's
being pinned down by this Queen right
here this Queens kind of just in defense
mode
on the other side black can easily get
this rook involved into the game his
lights for a bishop is very dangerous
can take this pawn anytime he wants to
here on h5 all of a sudden after pawn to
b3 this opens up the door for this
bishop to get involved into the action
so black has a much better game looking
right now we see Quinn over here to be
one since it was being attacked by the
rook here on c8 a pawn here it's a b3
just opening up the doors we talked
about Knight taking on b3 and that's
just kind of the the consolation that
black decided that he would he would
have there he's gonna give up that pawn
of material so that he can have this
active piece here on a5 because it was
kind of stuck on board but other bishops
gonna come back here to b6 which is
completely fine pawn here to a5 now
Bishop back here to a7 he kind of likes
his position al you can always have a
discovered attack with pawn here to d3
in this Knights a little bit more out of
the way out here on b3
you know the night the Queen and the
rook really need to be over on the Kings
side kind of help in the attack but
right now they are not so if we continue
King over here to g1 a bishop here to f5
bishop appear to e4 probably another big
mistake just bringing the bishop there
just not sure if he saw he always had
just Queen here to e1 I
this is completely reasonable but decide
to play Bishop here to e4
but then Queens the g5 is just
devastating I'm he really needed to keep
his Bishop at home from here there's
there's no way to really stop this he
plays King here to f1 and then
Queen here to f4 is just kind of game
over if we now see the bishop take here
on f5 okay well that's gonna be bad
because then pawn here to d3
this just opens up the door this Bishop
can't move but the Queen can come down
checkmate
that's definitely gonna be bad if we
come back instead of the the bishop
taking knight here to d2 potentially
then all of a sudden rook down here to
see two if the Queen takes that all of a
sudden pawn to a d3 discovered checkmate
attack the the Queen's gonna fall you
know that's no good if we even come back
and say instead of this okay let's get
the Queen involved to d3 let's go ahead
and stop this pawn from coming up but
then we just see this Bishop fall and
then even if the Queen comes over here
doesn't matter the Queen captures and
then all of a sudden this Bishop takes
here on h1 so all in all things just go
really really really bad and so after
the Queen comes here to f4 we do see the
resignation for Wesley so just made too
many mistakes in the game I was kind of
disappointed to see all the mistakes
that I really thought when we saw that
f3 move early on and the King's Indian
or the nimzo-indian defense excuse me
that he had some masterful plan cooked
up that we're gonna see some crazy
attack but didn't happen made some
mistakes and Levon Aronian is now in
first place he has three points out of
the four matches so far so congrats to
him anytime you can play the black
pieces and get a win that's gonna be a
good day in the office so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video around four we
have five more rounds to go so if the
guys are enjoying this tournament and
I'll see you all in the next video
thanks for watching